I want to start by thanking members of
the Yale Center for British art staff
who have made special efforts towards
the end
Abagail armistead Marc Aronson Alejandra
Peterson Castillo Elinor Hughes Rick
Johnson Lynne Bell Rose and Erica Stagg
Meyer and Paul Mitchell of Paul Mitchell
limited in London provided the frames
for Mark's paintings which you'll see
upstairs it's really been a great
pleasure to work with mark Leonard on
the installation that you will see on
the fourth floor of our building he's a
very talented artist but he's also
supremely supremely professional
level-headed and a model of kind and
courteous working practices so thank you
very much mark for the pleasurable
experience of working with you John
Constable who was born in 1776 and died
in 1837 is an almost palpable presence
here at the center we have more than 60
paintings by constable in the museum
making him the artist represented by the
largest number of works in our paintings
collection and we also have seven pure
cloud studies by the artist the largest
group of such works in any museum
collection working with mark to Shepherd
through his project allowed me to take
the cloud studies off of the walls I
looked at the backs of the panel's
searching for notations and wondered it
the perfect completeness of these
modestly sized works and you're seeing
one about 15 times larger than it is
upstairs so you must come up to the
exhibition afterwards and have a look
but it's this kind of open reappraisal
followed by a deepening historical
consciousness about constables work that
I hope marks daring installation will
provoke it certainly asks and I think
even demands of us as museum visitors
and as art historians to look and new at
constables work mark Leonard delicately
weaves a deep respect for the historical
work of art with a bold contemporary
practice as an artist he's one of the
most respected paintings restore is
working today and mark has studied and
treated paintings by Reynolds Renoir
Rembrandt and Velasquez to name just a
very few of the hundreds and even
thousands of artists and that he's
worked on he studied our studio art art
history and chemistry at Oberlin College
and earned a master's degree in art
history and a diploma in art
conservation from the Institute of Fine
Arts New York University and as Amy
mentioned he completed his training
under the guidance of John brely at the
Metropolitan Museum
Bart mark done spent 26 years at the
Jade Paul getting Museum in Los Angeles
eventually becoming head of the
paintings conservation department during
his last years at the Getty mark
returned to making his own paintings and
drawings again something that he had
done when he was a student and a young
conservator after stepping down from his
position at the Getty mark spent nearly
two years working on the suite of
paintings upstairs and it's interesting
to me that this is about the same amount
of time that constable devoted to his
Cloud studies earlier this year as Amy
mentioned mark was named chief
conservator of the Dallas Museum of Fine
Arts please join me in welcoming mark
Leonard to the podium where he will
deliver a lecture titled constables
cloud studies personal thoughts on his
most personal works
Thank You Cassandra and Amy for those
very kind words and my heartfelt thanks
to you as well for giving me the chance
to take what has proven to be a
wonderful journey of exploration and
discovery with this project and my
thanks to all of you as well for coming
this evening some of the home I know
have come very long distances and I'm
very flattered and grateful to see you
in the audience I must also thank my
friends and colleagues here at the Yale
Center for British art who have given
very generously of their time and
support I won't repeat the names that
have already already been mentioned but
let me simply extend my gratitude to
everyone on staff for not only making me
feel welcome but for doing so much to
facilitate my work I mentioned that this
has been a journey of sorts and while
thinking about the organization of this
evenings lecture I thought it might be
best to have it follow the story of how
this project came about tracing the
pathway that led to the exhibition which
is now in the galleries upstairs as a
short but important preface to that
story though let's begin with constable
himself as it is his work that provided
the inspiration for this project and
catalyzed the journey a great deal of
art historical ink has been spilled for
constable studies including the Cloud
studies that had been the focus of my
attention and there are a number of
people here tonight who know quite a lot
more about constable than I do so
there's little need for a lengthy
overview of his life and work but there
are as well some of you who may not be
so familiar with constable so for all of
us I thought it might be useful to set
the stage with a bit of background John
Constable was born in June of 1776 in
the village of East Burke halt in
Suffolk the son of Golding and an
constable his father ran a successful
milling business which eventually
expanded into a shipping business
transporting a variety of goods ranging
from grain to coal on the River Stour a
river that became one of a constables
favoured subjects later in life Golding
constable thought that his son John
might eventually take over the family
business but it was not to be in 1799
constable was admitted to study art at
the Royal Academy in London and he first
exhibited his work there in 1802 at the
age of 26 although his early works
included port
and religious subjects he ultimately
followed his passion for nature and
turned to landscape painting you see one
of his early masterpieces a work
commissioned in 1816 by the owner of
this property known as woven ho Park
which now hangs in the National Gallery
in Washington on a personal note this is
the picture that I inevitably search for
whenever I visit the National Gallery
and it is easily one of my favourites of
constables works it captures the perfect
beauty of a perfectly glorious day in
the English countryside it is important
to note though that the gentle beauty of
nature is seen in constables eyes
through the lens of human endeavours and
thus the fences spillways swans cows and
of course the great house right at the
center of it all play not only an
important role in the framework of the
composition but on a deeper level the
presence underscores man's influence in
taming and composing the natural
landscape
constable solve his first large campus
in 1819 the spectacular scene known as
the white horse which is now in the
Frick Collection this is the River Stour
by the way and we see a tow horse in a
ferry crossing the river from one bank
to the other
constable famously referred to these
compositions as a six-footers because
they literally were six feet across the
Yale Center for British art is fortunate
to have two six-footers in its
collection the first datings were around
the same time as the Frick picture this
view of Stratford Mill this is in fact
one of two six-foot versions of the same
composition as it was constables custom
to produce full scale studies of his
large landscapes before producing a
highly finished version of the scene
the Yale version in this case is the
study the finished version is in the
National Gallery in London and the
surface of the Yale picture is
wonderfully fresh rough and direct due
to the fact that it was constables
working version of the scene in 1821
constable who was elected and associate
of the Royal Academy and he continued to
pursue a successful career from that
point forward a turning point occurred
in 1828 when after the death of his wife
his anxieties over the loss introduced a
different perspective to
landscapes the other 6-footer at Yale
the magnificent view of the ruins have
had the Hadley castle at the mouth of
the Thames was painted in 1829 and
portrays a very different relationship
between man and nature rather than a
sunlit scene depicting perfect harmonies
between the natural landscape and human
endeavours we see an overwhelming vista
of nature untamed after a stormy night
with what had become the ruins of man's
endeavours anchoring the scene at the
left
but despite the depiction of decay there
was also a wonder and a sense of hope
introduced by the rays of light breaking
through the tumbling bands of clouds the
race across the vast sky it's also
interesting to note and this is the sort
of compositional detail that you hear
more about later on the constable chose
to divide the picture quite literally in
two equal halves as the horizon line
moves directly across the center of the
composition adding to the sense of
tension between the relentless moving of
the sky and the weighty anchor of the
landscape and ruins below my focus on
constable has been in terms of scale on
the opposite spectrum from the big six
footers constable produced a large
number of oil sketches relatively quick
sketches painted on small sheets of
paper some produced outdoors and others
in his studio these three all in the
Yale collection and all dating to 1821
were like all of his studies on paper
and unlike his or large canvas paintings
never intended for sale or public
viewing they were personal works used as
a means of exploring ways in which to
capture glimpses of the natural world
that could could then inform the more
finished formality of his canvas
paintings among the most powerful and
intimate of the oil sketches were the
pure cloud studies painted during the
summers of 1821 and 1822 when constable
and his family were in residence in
Hempstead just outside London these
studies have no hint of landscape and
consequently no hint of human presence
dozens of the seductive works have
survived such as these two brilliant
examples which have found our way to the
Frick Collection
and they remain quite rightly among the
most beloved and desirable works from
constables legacy they are in one sense
working exercises exploring the ways in
which various atmospheric effects could
be captured through the proper handling
of paint on the reverse of many of the
studies constable jotted down the date
and time and in some cases added
meteorological observations as well as
personal reminders if and when he
referred to them back in the studio at
some point but for us they are also a
direct link to the uninhibited hand eye
and mind of the artist and provide a
glimpse of an intensely personal
exploration of the natural world nearly
all of these small studies were in
constable studio at the time of his
death as he never intended them for
anything other than his own private use
it was only after his death that the
paper sketches were mounted onto canvas
or to panel placed in frames and offered
for sale as finished works of art in
their own right
collectors have always been drawn to
them and fortunately for us mr. melon
who was among the most avid collectors
of constables larger-scale works also
had a passion for oil sketches and that
collection which we see here in a view
of mr. Mallen's New York residence and
as it is usually installed in the
galleries upstairs now gives all of us a
very public view of constables most
private works so with that bit of
background I can now begin to tell the
story of my own journey with constable
which began quite some time ago with a
picture that we've already seen in the
late 1970's and early 1980s I was
working in the paintings conservation
department at the Metropolitan Museum of
Art as a young conservator at the start
of a career I had the unusual privilege
of finding simply extraordinary works of
art sitting on my easel one of those was
the white horse from the Frick which was
cleaned by my mentor John Brealey who as
we've heard earlier was also an advisor
to mr. melon and cared for many of the
pictures in his collection after
completion of the cleaning John
entrusted me to carry out the retouching
of some minor damages throughout the
clouds and sky during the time that I
was the met that during the time that I
was at the mat the department also
worked with the collection of paintings
from the Yale Center for British art
do not only to John's working
relationship with mr. Mallen but also
because of his close friendship with Ted
Pillsbury who was the director of the
Yale Center for British art at that
point in time the very first picture
that I cleaned and restored for Yale was
this full-length portrait of the first
Earl Granville painted by Thomas
Lawrence in the early years of the 19th
century
I left the Met in 1983 and headed west
where I spent the following 26 years in
the paintings conservation department at
the Jay paul Getty Museum fortunately I
maintained close ties not only with the
Yale Center for British art during those
years but with the Yale University Art
Gallery as well I worked closely with
mark Aronson who is now I am happy to
say and as you've heard the first
in-house paintings conservator at the
Yale Center for British art when he was
working across the street for a number
of years in the late 1990s the Getty
partnered with mark
paddy garland and their colleagues at
the Yale University Art Gallery on a
project that focused upon the gallery's
collection of early Italian Renaissance
paintings just prior to my retirement
from the Getty and before Mark had moved
from across the street I had the chance
to work with this self-portrait by Sir
Joshua Reynolds painted around 1750 when
Reynolds would have been in his late 20s
so as you can see my relationship with
Yale was for many years based upon my
work as a conservator my relationship
for the Constable project however has
been based upon my more recent work as
an artist although I am beginning to
understand largely as a result of my
time spent with Constable over the past
couple of years what an important role
my conservation career has played in
influencing the ways in which I go about
creating my own work to that end I
thought we might take just a quick look
at just one example of conservation work
and then some examples of my own work
prior to the start of the Constable
project this classically composed
picture by the Northern Renaissance
artist Petrus Christus depicting the
Virgin and Child in an archway dates to
1450 and is now in the Museum of Fine
Arts in Budapest Hungary one of the
world's great encyclopedic collections
and I had the chance to work on it a
number of years ago at the Getty the
picture which is on panel entered the
collection in Budapest in the late 19th
century and had most likely not been
touched since that time although
beautiful and jewel light in
precision and handling the paint surface
was buried beneath an obscuring fog of
dirt and discoloured varnish and the old
restorations had changed and discolored
to a disturbing degree which is
particularly evident in the repainting
found in a large hole at the center of
the sky removal of the labor removal of
the layers of dirt and varnish revealed
a number of old losses most likely
caused by some catastrophic event in the
past when the picture was dropped her
mishandled as frightening as these
losses appeared when the picture was in
its clean state it's essential to
realize that they added up to a fairly
minor problem it's fortunate that the
majority of the losses occurred in areas
of drapery landscape and the
architectural framework and not in the
superbly rendered flesh tones so that
the tender relationship between the
mother and child which is at the core of
the meaning of the picture was not
interrupted the first step in the
restoration process was to under paint
the losses with a flat water-based
gouache paint that was somewhat lighter
in tone and more intense in color than
surrounding areas by doing so a smooth
opaque foundation for reconstructing the
misty missing areas was easily laid in
place and the losses themselves were
robbed of some of their power the
strength and presence of the original
began to dominate as the static noise of
the damages began to disappear once the
picture was varnished the retouches were
completed with a synthetic resin based
paint a paint specifically manufactured
for use in conservation as if not only
remains very stable but can also be
easily distinguished from the oil paint
of the original work if and when it has
to be removed in the future the damages
were eventually forgotten as the
restoration came to a close and the
luminous atmosphere of the scene was
regained I became a restorer through a
fairly standard route following an
undergraduate course of study at Oberlin
College which was a mix of studio art
art history and chemistry and then
moving on to New York University for
graduate degrees in art history and
conservation I stopped doing my own work
when I moved to New York without regret
at the time as I had decided to focus
completely on becoming a paintings
restorer several years ago though I
began to have urges to return to
creating my own work and I decided to
begin to do so by embracing the thing
that I knew well the materials that I
had used in restoration for decades and
some of the pictures that I had come to
know so well as they moved on and off my
easel over that time I began a series of
exercises that drew from the works that
I knew such as this card players from
Minneapolis by the doctor 17th century
artist Hendrik tare broken
I took a detail from the picture the
drapery in the lower right corner and
re-invented it as a figurative
abstraction when I first applied for a
position at the Met back in the 1970s I
brought along a portfolio of my own
paintings to show to John really he was
complimentary about it but told me
straight out that he hoped that I had no
intention of working both as a painter
and a paintings restorer as it would be
impossible to succeed at both during the
time that I was continuing to work at
the Getty as a restorer but also
starting to explore my own creative
urges I finally came to a fuller
understanding of why he had taken such a
firm stand on the issue on the one hand
there's a wonderful similarity between
the dialog that takes place between the
restorer and paintings on his easel and
that restore a response to the picture
as it evolves and changes during the
course of treatment in the same way
there's a dialogue between the painter
and his own work on the easel and the
changes that take place during the
course of creation lead the painter
through the work but there's a
significant difference as well as the
restorer must disappear in service to
the artist and the painter on the other
hand must make sure that his soul is
made manifest as my own work began to
evolve
I found it increasingly difficult to
turn on and turn off those two very
different mindsets with ease so I opted
to retire from my conservation work in
order to focus full-time on my own
drawings and paintings so that I could
see where things might lead I had
already begun to search for a visual
motif with an underlying conceptual
format that I could find both visually
and emotionally engaging and within just
a few days of retiring retiring I came
up with a theme that I was certain I
could explore for quite some time my
thought process in this regard was again
to embrace something that I already knew
but something that would also touch upon
a larger shared human
experience I settled upon the
relationship between love and loss a
relationship that everyone comes to
understand as it is nearly impossible to
have love in your life with or without
also risking the loss to which we might
eventually lead and while thinking about
how those two emotional experiences are
intimately woven together the visual
motif evolved quite naturally and you
see it here and not surprisingly I refer
to these pictures as weavings use of a
grid structure a structure that I've
always been drawn to provided an ordered
underlying framework for exploration of
what is in fact quite a messy emotional
theme I continued to build upon my past
experience with old master paintings as
in this triptych which among other
things references the formats of
Northern European Renaissance altar
pieces with wings at the left and right
of the central panel painted in Greece
on I was very fortunate that Louis Stern
whose gallery Louis Stern Fine Arts has
been a mainstay of the Los Angeles art
scene for many years took an interest in
my work and gave me my first solo
exhibition I was equally fortunate that
Amy Myers knowing of my long association
with Yale invited me to consider doing
some work that might reflect upon the
collections at the Yale Center for
British art I spent a couple of days in
New Haven New Haven wandering the
galleries thinking about what might work
Lauren's portrait was a logical
candidate and you see him lurking in the
background of this shot of the constable
gallery but I kept returning to the
constable studies and the cloud studies
in particular drawn in part to the fact
that there was such a critical mass of
them here but also to the fact that they
are from my aspect but from my
perspective such intensely personal
works was such a universal appeal the
project began and of course it was
inevitable inevitable that I would start
looking at clouds with a new interest
don't worry I won't bore you with the
hundreds of photos that I took which
would put you in the position of hapless
dinner guests who were forced to look at
the hosts vacation photos but as you
might imagine once I started looking at
clouds with a new perspective it hasn't
been easy to stop my partner Ken and I
were living in the desert at this point
and this was the view from our kitchen
on many evenings there's not a lot of
shared imagery between the deserts of
Southern
and the gentle green landscapes of
Constable's countryside but there were
moments when the clouds that were
visible from our kitchen table
another more stormy sky seen here were
in fact surprisingly reminiscent of
constable studies and you see another of
the Yale studies here the Yale Center
for British art supplied me with full
scale prints of all of their collection
of constable studies and I immediately
and randomly pinned them on the wall of
my studio so that I could look at them
and think about them on a daily basis
excuse me for one second it was clear to
me that the last thing the world needed
was a series of paintings of clouds
which could only stand in poor
comparison to cup two constables
considerable achievements so instead
gave thought to developing a visual
motif that would reference constables
work and resonate with it but not
replicate or imitate it this was in fact
quite a daunting task and in the
isolation of my studio I found myself
more fearful than hopeful about the
prospects how could I make a meaningful
reference to the underlying and
universally appealing conceptual themes
in constables works and how could my own
work sit comfortably in a purely visual
sense in the same galleries as the
constable studies I managed to overcome
some of those fears during the trip to
London where by fortunate coincidence
the Dulwich picture gallery had on view
a spectacularly insightful exhibition
pairing the work of the 20th century
artist site Twombly with the work of the
17th century french painter nicolas
poussin
i could think of no two artists who had
less to do with each other visually than
Twombly and Poussin and couldn't imagine
how an exhibition that integrated their
work could possibly succeed but succeed
it did in no small part because of the
shared conceptual strengths that
resonated between the two artists and
here you see poussez rape of the SE
vines below and above it Tom Lee's
reflection upon the same subject as to
development of a visual motif I wrestled
with how I might continue to take
advantage of the underlying framework
that a compositional grid provides for
exploring visual anymore
themes and to that end excuse me I found
an answer in an exhibition at the
National Gallery in London which
explored the connections between the
work of Richard Rao
Bridget Riley whose work you see here
and old master paintings such as the
great Cezanne bathers from the gallery's
own collection Riley's paintings are
remarkably fluid but they are built upon
an underlying grid in this case one with
strong verticals and diagonals that
allows for development of a focused and
directed sense of complex and
overlapping movements and they often
share much in common and work in
comfortable relationship with all the
master paintings I returned home from
London and set to work on finding a
visual motif that would reference the
movement and motion of constables clouds
I had also begun to do a great deal of
reading about constable and about the
cloud studies in particular in his own
lectures and writings constable often
referred to the lanes of clouds that
appear in the sky and art historians
often favor use of the word locomotion
to describe the sense of continuous
tumbling movement of constables clouds
across the skies now the word locomotion
does not to my knowledge appear anywhere
in constables writings but the term
locomotive engine was in use to describe
steam-powered engines as early as 1814
so it's not even inconceivable that he
was at least familiar with the term as
well in any event thinking of a grid and
thinking of locomotion reminded me of an
early lesson from studio art classes
that a very simple way of drawing the
repetitive tumbling movement of a rope
is to make use of a grid structure to
establish the framework for developing
the image a series of curved lines drawn
between equally spaced points on a grid
will establish the outlines of the forms
and varying the format of the grid will
allow for an infinite variety of shapes
and sizes
I liked the sense of tumbling motion
that this motif suggested as well as the
underlying sense of tension I also felt
that it had good potential for
resonating with the lanes of clouds that
constable composed in his studies and
here you see a rough pencil sketch on
graph paper which was my first venture
in the
flourishing of this motif with those
thoughts in mind I spent a very
enjoyable week in residence in New Haven
mark Aronson generously set me up in a
corner of the conservation studio here
and as you can see I was given the
unique opportunity to have some of the
constable studies very close at hand
I also benefited from resources of the
libraries here where I was able not only
to work my way with some effort through
some of constables writings and my only
comment in that regard is that there's a
good reason why we remember constable as
a great artist and not as a brilliant
writer but I was able to bring myself up
to speed on some of the science of
meteorology as well although I must
admit that myself education in that
regard tended to favor illustrations in
picture books such as this one rather
than the more impenetrable scientific
tomes
I also continued to look at clouds and
here's a view from my hotel window and
New Haven during that week the
next-to-last of these types of shots
that will force upon you tonight but a
shot that provides a nice segue into a
closer look at constables clouds mark
Aronson offered to carry out some
technical studies on one of the Yale
pictures my primary interest in that
regard was to have a look at the layered
structure of the studies which I hoped
would confirm what seemed to be to the
naked eye a quite straightforward method
of painting a small sample from this
particular study was taken for analysis
and the area of the sample is shown here
as a small red dot at the bottom edge of
the composition and the results were not
altogether surprising you're seeing the
paint sample here turned on its side and
under magnification and from the bottom
up we can read the progression as
follows this remnant of a transparent
yellow film at the bottom of the sample
may indicate that the paper support was
first prepared with a sizing in order to
seal the paper fibers and prevent the
oil paint from leaching medium into the
paper a comparative thick and complex
layer of purplish colored paint was
applied over the entire sheet of paper
as a ground there are particles of lead
white red LED black and most likely iron
earth pigments and as we'll see when we
look at a number of other studies this
plum colored preparation not only served
as an under paint but was left exposed
in
many areas to give the illusion of deep
shadows in the clouds the thin layer of
paint at the very top of the sample
contains primarily lead white and
Prussian blue and the increased density
of the blue towards the top of the layer
suggests that this may have been a wet
and too wet blending of several
brushstrokes in order to achieve the
final surface effect with this as
background it was time to begin working
more directly with the studies and I
opted to take this first step by once
again following my habit of turning to
something that I knew well color
matching if there's one thing that a
painting restorer is required to have in
his or her arsenal of tools is the
ability to match colors I set up a
pencil grid on a panel and assigned each
of the five vertical rows to one of the
constable studies and then deconstructed
their palettes moving from top to bottom
across each of the compositions in this
particular study for example the plum
colored preparatory layer which remains
visible throughout much of the upper
portion of the composition in the
shadowed underbellies of the clouds
gives way to the light Prussian blue of
the sky the silvery gray of the distant
clouds the deep Prussian blue of the
horizon and the yellow ochres of the
sunlit foreground landscape in a few of
the studies constable did not use the
plum colored under paint instead relying
upon the light grayish color of the
paper itself as the basis for the
palette resulting in a more ethereal
sense of air and atmosphere in this
particular study he did apply what
appears to be an overall layer of a
slightly greenish blue color as a light
under paint and then used a darker blue
on top of that to begin to create the
illusion of depth a much lighter blue
tinted with ogor to create a yellowish
grace gumbal was added as a final touch
throughout the lower right corner and
then the clouds were sculpted with
varying shades of white and gray on top
of the background of open sky in this
sunset view a light salmon color was
applied as a preliminary layer
throughout much of the lower portion of
the composition and then alternating
bands of yellows and varying shades of
Blues were used to capture the illusion
of the warm light of
hidden behind the cool gray shadows of
the clouds in light of the fact that
this in terms of composition is one of
the simpler studies at Yale as a
primarily focuses upon a single lane of
clouds moving across the sky I referred
to it for a pencil study of my own first
establishing a grid grid lines for the
compositional borders then providing the
framework for the Rope motif and once
the forms were completed finishing up
with references to the palette that
constable used in his study this laid
the groundwork for a painted response to
the same composition which you see here
the grid lines were laid out on the
prepared surface of the panel and a flat
water based gouache under paint was used
to block in the basic colors of the
palette and you can see the salmon
colored gouache at the bottom of the
composition as well as glimpses of a
violent gray colored gouache under paint
at either end of the rope the surface
was then varnished and some of the
surfaces were finished with a synthetic
resin based paint you might recall this
two-step method of painting from the
retouching that we saw earlier this
evening on the Budapest Petrus Christus
and it's a process that I've chosen to
use in my own work as it is not only a
technique that I know well and enjoy
handling but it results in a visual
sense of depth and complexity but also
creates a sense of animated vibration on
the surface due to the quick drying
nature of the synthetic resin paints
which must be applied in short quick
strokes this all seemed promising but I
felt that there was still a need for an
additional visual motif one that would
continue to reflect upon the imagery
found in constable studies but one that
could also play a role in introducing an
additional emotional element that would
reflect some of my own interests and
perspectives as many of you know
constables contemporaries in Germany in
the early part of the 19th century took
a somewhat different approach to
landscape painting an approach that was
no less attuned to the study of natural
phenomena but decidedly more romantic
more contempt more contemplative and
more spiritual in its interpretation of
man's relationship to nature Caspar
David Friedrich was the master of this
tradition of German Romantic landscape
painting and his work has always held in
intend
appeal for me this is one of only three
paintings by Friedrich in the United
States and it is a picture that I know
well as I was able to repair clean and
restore it after it was acquired by the
Getty in 1993 in the moonlit Twilight a
solid solitary introspective figure
stands in front of an arrangement of
rocks that are in fact a megalithic tomb
and the entire scene is lit by the orb
of the crescent moon and the nearby
evening star the float above in the
purple sky the picture is of course a
technical wonder particularly in
Friedreich's depiction of the evening
fog moving into the stand of trees in
the background but at its core it is a
profound meditation upon the
relationship between life and death I
thought there might prove to be a useful
useful relationship between the tumbling
movement of the rope motif and the
floating mystical presence of an orb
motif that would work in my reflections
upon constable studies so on the same
panel as the initial painted study I
worked up some orbs using the plum
colored under paint from constables
palette which coincident coincidentally
was nicely reminiscent of Friedreich's
twilit sky and the orbs seemed to float
in a comfortable relationship with the
adjacent imagery finally as the week
began to draw to a close I was able to
see how the palettes and the motifs that
I had explored might resonate with the
constables themselves as they'd always
been my hopeful thought that my pictures
might eventually find their way into the
galleries with the constable studies one
unexpected but welcome surprise for me
during that week was when I was shown
this extraordinary watercolor of a
rainbow from the Yale Center for British
art collections my first thought was
that it could easily be mistaken as a
recent work by a drew Shay but is it is
of course a work by John Constable
dating to 1827 when it was included
alongside the oil sketch that had been
the focus of my work during the week
everything seemed to fit comfortably at
the end of the week we moved upstairs to
the constable galleries for a seminar
with interest interested staff from the
centre and the art gallery and at least
as far as I know everyone seemed pleased
with the potential and we agreed that
I'd go back to the desert and get to
work in earnest on the series
you'll remember this view that we saw
earlier of the virtual constable gallery
in my studio with the images arranged in
random fashion before my week of
residency in New Haven
here's how it looked a few days after my
return ordered and arranged based upon
some new insights and a clearer sense of
direction I had decided to focus upon
nine of the studies four of the smaller
landscape sketches and five of the pure
cloud studies the smallest sketches
varied in size but I wanted to have a
unifying theme for the four that I had
chosen so I opted to use four panels of
identical outer dimensions and tailor
the painted surface on each panel to the
exact size of the corresponding
constable sketch in light of the fact
that constable painted his studies on
sheets of white paper I opted to use
white panels and to retain a border at
the edges in order to not only reference
Constable's original choice of a support
but to leave exposed the grid notations
that I'd be using in the development of
each of the compositions as I had
already spent a great deal of time with
this particular study it was the logical
candidate for the first finished work of
my own and here you see on the right
with the dimensions of the painted
surface identical to the constable study
the underlying grid notations still
visible at the edges and the palette and
composition of the constable including
the tiny strip of grey landscape which
runs across the bottom edge which is so
crucial in lending a sense of scale to
this diminutive work reflected in my own
vocabulary now as an aside this is the
part of the lecturer my commentary
becomes a bit tricky as I can't refer to
my own work in the same reverential
terms that I'm using for the constables
and this lecture may have already
crossed the boundary into hopeless self
absorption so my apologies of my
comments about my own paintings are
confined to some fairly prosaic details
but I'll leave it to the paintings
themselves to do the speaking and to the
critics curators art historians and for
all of you as viewers to come to your
own decisions as to their merit or
interest and to explore what I hope you
will find to be the different levels of
meanings in the works one of the
landscape sketches that I found the most
compelling was this small study also
from 1821 with the lanes of clouds
racing across its huge expansive sky
above at Sunday
old sun-dappled sliver of landscape at
first glance this is a simple depiction
of a classically sunny day in the
English countryside as casual as if we
ourselves had caught it in a tourist
snapshot but in fact there's nothing
casual about it it's important to
remember that when constable is working
outdoors the sky was in constant motion
he did not have the luxury of capturing
a single moment but had to work with
many moments over the course of an hour
or two and he had to assemble those
moments into a meaningful hole if we
look at the underlying structure of this
composition the rigorous assembly of the
composition becomes evident the clouds
move in perfect perspectival progression
from the two large shapes that float
above our heads these two here to the
overlapping lanes that blend to into a
seamless band of grays and blues at the
horizon there is a central cloud this
one right here dead center of the
composition that displays the full range
of colors from the brilliant white
highlights to deeply shadowed interiors
the deep blue distant landscape is in
the shape of the triangle from the lower
right to the centre back down to the
lower left reaching its peak at dead
center just below the central cloud
which enables it to act as a kind of
fulcrum for the scene which moves around
it and a final stroke of brilliant white
paint right here again placed a dead
center reinforces the centrality of the
composition were these conscious and
deliberate choices on Constable's part
we certainly don't see underlying
gridlines laying out these geometric
devices so it is perhaps more
appropriate to say that he was such a
master of composition that he simply
couldn't help but assemble a framework
that achieved perfection and balance in
my reflection upon this study I act with
the underlying structures of the
composition beginning with the wavy
shapes above and a central orb which is
accompanied by two supporting players
the sunlit horizontal band at the bottom
reflects the light of the sky and the
triangular element has a glowing spot of
white at its core I explored similar
themes in to more of the landscape
sketches
focusing upon the sharp contrast between
the dark cool forms of the clouds and
the startling slash of yellow light in
this particular study in building upon
that Karos euro an italian word which
literally means light dark and a term
that was a favorite of constables in my
response and then in this seascape which
states to 1828 a bit later than most of
the other studies I focused upon the
fact that constable tilted his lanes of
clouds so that they form strong
diagonals moving towards the arc of
landscape at the far right of the scene
after working with this with these
smaller landscape sketches I felt more
confident to move on to the pure cloud
studies where any interest in the
landscape below had given way completely
to Constable's explorations of the sky
above most of the pure cloud studies
make use of two basic formats one of
which was almost but not quite square
the study that you see here measures
just about nine by eleven inches
it's very rare prior to the 20th century
to find an artist who worked in a
perfectly square format particularly an
artist such as constable who clearly
preferred the horizontal formats to
which landscapes were well suited but
I've always been attracted to the
perfect square given its inherent
strength and insistent presence so for
the almost square cloud studies I opted
to work on twelve by twelve inch panels
and again tailored the painted surfaces
to match the dimensions of the
individual studies the clouds in this
particular study Ross rush across the
composition in the now-familiar lanes
but the power of their movement is
indicated by the strong leaning of the
forms towards the right and heightened
by the strong contrast between light and
dark here's the way that my response to
it began to take shape at the
underpainting stage the orbs and ropes
were blocked in with a plum colored
gouache and the background sky was a
field of light Prussian blue tying the
picture closely two constables original
palette and here is the final result
after completion of glazing and
scumbling with a synthetic resin based
paint an application of the final
varnish lamé layers I'm showing you
another of the pure cloud studies as I
first encountered it in the form of its
official photographic documentation
it was only after I had spent some time
with the other studies and also had a
chance to discuss the issue with Angus
Trumble and with Cassandra that we came
to realize that as you see it now it is
in fact upside down as constable always
placed the heaviest masses of his clouds
at the top of his compositions so that
they would give the impression of
floating overhead and these large forms
merged into progressively smaller lanes
as the scene moves towards the distance
so here it is in its proper orientation
and my reflection upon it the eye is led
into the scene by means of a strong
horizontal band which enters at the
upper-left the central mass is at the
top of the composition are crowded
together adding weight and perhaps
characterizing a sense of impending
storm these large forms sit directly
above a distinct and brightly lit Lane
of clouds which in turn is supported by
consecutive and tightly packed and
overlapping horizontal bands of clouds
providing a kind of visual pedestal for
the dominant shapes above two of the
most beautiful cloud studies in the Yale
collection are in the second format that
constable used for these sketches which
rather than being nearly square make use
of an extended horizontal sheet of paper
this format allowed for capturing a much
broader wider section of the sky and
subsequently the studies in this mode
tend to be even more expansive in their
sense of space and light this study has
two great masses of clouds
tucked behind a lane of clouds and this
Lane may not be at a parent at first but
there is a continuous horizontal band
that runs from left to right right
across there smaller masses float in
front of and around these main elements
and touches of blue sky lend a sense of
depth yet despite the horizontal format
there is a centrality to the composition
which is essentially divided down the
middle by means of the bright white
highlights found at the edges of the
strongly backed thick clouds the study
has also a bit unusual in the constable
use of warm color under paint and the
slight wear of the surface has exposed
this preparatory layer particularly in
the large cloud mass at the left so I
opted to include that visual phenomenon
and bit of history in my own response
the second horizontal format study at
Yale is this ethereal view of light
wispy clouds floating across a pale yet
brightly lit sky the usual distinct
lanes of clouds are visible particularly
in the two horizontal bands at the
bottom of the composition which provide
a visual foundation for the rest of the
open scene isolated groups then move
subtly upwards from the lower left to
the upper right heightening the sense of
openness and gentle floating movement
but despite the open nature of the scene
constable still chose to line up the
clouds in the upper center directly on
the vertical centerline of the
composition subtle variations in the
palate also exist notably the touch of
deep blues and grays in the cloud that
is exiting the scene at the far right
and I've referenced that subtle increase
in Carlos girl in my response we can
finish up this overview of the series
before moving on to a few footnotes
about the project with one of the most
powerful of Constable studies at Yale
it's an exceptionally strong picture
with a bright slash of light cutting
through the right center of the
composition played against the powerful
dark masses at the left and top despite
the dramatic and seemingly transitory
impact of the composition as you will no
doubt suspect by now it is not just a
massive random clouds and the emotional
impact depends heavily on the underlying
structure there is a wide lane of clouds
running across the bottom of the picture
right here and three large masses that
sit behind and above this lower band the
upper right and upper left corners of
the composition are treated almost like
spandrels refocusing our attention back
towards the center of the scene hints of
blue appear here and there not so much
as a means of depicting the infinite
blue sky beyond but just suggesting its
presence those were some of the themes
that I responded to in my own work
building the composition from the bottom
up starting with a weighty band that
moves from dark to light as it
transverses the composition and then
condensing the strong contrasts of light
and shadow into a tightly packed
relationship between three floating orbs
thus pandals of the upper left and right
are intended to lead
I back-end is the composition and
glimpses of the eternal promise of blue
sky can be seen beyond the lower band
and the insistent flatness of these
areas is intended to create some tension
between the flat plains up of
abstraction and the illusory and
insistent sense of form in the rope and
orms when I had finished this particular
study which was the last in the series
of nine smaller paintings in this
project I began to have a sense of
closure I had learned quite a bit from
the process of looking so intensely at
constables work but right from the
beginning of this project I had in mind
to bring things to completion by working
on two larger format panels that would
echo constables more formal landscape
compositions on the way home back to
Palm Springs after my initial week in
residency at Yale flying into the Denver
Airport I was given some thought I was
giving some thought as to what shape a
larger landscape might take and how I
might continue a grid-like format
throughout a large landscape composition
and as we approached the airport I
looked out over what was one of the most
beautiful and far-reaching grids that I
had ever seen perfectly composed and
cultivated fields of farmland stretching
as far as the horizon I made a quick
notation of it in my notebook and Ken
snapped this photo of it when it came
time to develop a larger format
composition it seemed logical and
appropriate to use what I had learned
from one of my own studies as the basis
for the sky and to place those forms as
a looming presence over the perspectival
grid below and you see that initial
layout in a preparatory pencil sketch
the Vantage of the vantage point is
quite high inspired by the perspective
that we as modern viewers of clouds
often enjoy when in an airplane but
inspired as well by the fact that
constable also often compose landscape
vistas as if they were seen from
slightly above which meant in some cases
that the skies were seen nearly straight
of on straight on emphasizing their
presence and underscoring their
importance the dark band of Prussian
blue at the distant horizon line and the
bright white white band just above it
are intended to reference classic
landscape painting techniques techniques
used by constable by Vienna by many
other landscape painters as well and the
contrast between the dark of the land
where it meets the light of the sky
in the far distance heightens a sense of
receding depth there remained but one
more picture to complete for the series
and work on that picture coincided with
an unexpected and unrelated event which
involved making a move to Texas to work
with the Dallas Museum of Art and the
development of its in-house conservation
program and here I promise is the last
of my cloud photos they don't have to
endure this one a view of sunrise from
our new house in Dallas for the second
of the larger landscape compositions I
opted to return to one of constables
works here at Yale as a point of
departure this ploughing scene in
Suffolk which dates to 1824 1825 is a
deceptively simple homage to the
traditions of 17th century Dutch
landscape painting the big sky format
the receding bands of trees and fields
in the distance and the patchwork of
light and shade across the countryside
are particularly reminiscent of the work
of Phillips Connick and here you see a
conic landscape from the 1670s which now
resides in the National Gallery in
London
constable scene is an emphatically
horizontal composition with layers of
landscape building towards the layers of
clouds which move steadfastly across the
sky from left to right the
counterbalance to the movement of nature
is provided by the cleverly positioned
horses Horseman and plough right here at
the centre which move from right to left
as they've been as if in an effort to
tame the onward March of the sky in the
opposite direction my own response to
the picture folks will focus more upon
the contrast between the warm huge
palette of the landscape and the cool
blues and grays of the sky as well as
the abstract relationships between the
insistently horizontal aspects of the
composition as work on the series came
to a close
conversations and planning for
installing the pictures in the constable
galleries here at Yale began to expand
issues of framing both in relation to
Yale's constables as well as to my own
pictures were part of those
conversations I was fortunate to be able
to time a visit to New Haven for a few
days last summer when Paul Mitchell long
regarded as one of the world's top frame
experts was also in town which gave all
of us the chance to not only hear his
well informed
and advice about the framing of Yale's
constables but to explore some choices
for my own pictures as well many of
Yale's constable studies have been
framed with modern reproduction frames
based upon period prototypes and the
scale and design of the mouldings suit
the small size and sketch-like aspects
of the works they fall somewhere between
the types of simple frames that we be
used for drawings or prints works on
paper as the constable studies are and
the types of more elaborate frames that
would be used for more small for small
but more highly finished oil paintings
the Royal Academy in London has a group
of constable studies that were donated
by constables daughter Isabel in 1884
and they remain in their mid 19th
century frames and I'm grateful to
Cassandra for providing these photos of
two of the paintings in storage at the
Royal Academy of course these cannot be
considered original frames as the
studies were never framed during
constables lifetime but they do reflect
early decisions by those who were close
to the artist as to how the studies
could be presented as you can see the
elegant simplicity of the
nineteenth-century moldings is not far
in sentiment from the type of frames
that have been chosen for many of the
Yale pictures to begin the search for
frames from my pictures Paul had turned
to his extraordinary collection of
period moldings and assembled a wide
array of potential candidates we spent
time in the constable gallery with the
frame corner photos as well as a few of
my own pictures this was essential to
the task as I wanted to make sure that
my pictures would fit comfortably not
only with the constables themselves but
within the constant within the context
of the constable gallery spaces and as
such we began to focus on frames that
referenced not only the studies but in a
somewhat more subtle way the details of
the architect Louie Kahn's choices of
materials and finishes in this
building's galleries it's an unusual way
to go about framing decisions but in
this particular case it seemed quite a
natural route to take since this is
where these pictures live while all of
these issues were considered we also
realized that it would be essential to
find a molding that would allow my
pictures to stand on their own the
molding that we all eventually decided
upon was the one that you see here
it is elegant in its simplicity yet
refined in the relationship between the
forward movement of the wood surface and
the gentle interior slope of the gilt
surface the would resonate select nicely
with Kahn's oak architectural details in
the galleries and here you see Cassandra
working with a layout of the exhibition
during the same time as our frame
discussions and the oak moldings of the
galleries are evident and everywhere the
gilt area references the constable study
frames yet as you see here in to
photoshop assemblies that Paul created
during our conversations the references
are subtle and the molding though
perhaps unexpected on contemporary works
of art works well with the paintings we
all agreed that it would be best to
frame all of the small studies with this
particular molding which would
underscore the unity of the series for
the two larger landscapes slightly
larger and more complex frames could be
used and for that purpose we settled
upon the corner sample that you see here
it obviously relates to the choice for
the smaller studies but the flatness of
the molding and the stronger rhythms of
the details work well with a larger
format of the final two pictures I
thought I'd bring things to a close by
means of one more image of my virtual
constable gallery which you see here as
it looked just after I had completed
work on the series of nine studies this
has been a priviledge tan inspirational
journey for me and I've learned a great
deal one of the more important lessons
has been that I no longer need to fear
the potential disconnect between my role
as a paintings conservator and my role
as an independent artist because of this
project which has given me a chance to
explore a significant group of old
master pictures while at the same time
exploring the themes of my own work the
two roles that had worked in conflict
with one another a few years ago now
seem able to a coexist more happily
constable may not have thought
consciously of his studies as intensely
personal works but as they were never
intended for sale or for that matter
even for viewing outside the confines of
his studio it meant that they were
unencumbered by the expectations of
patrons the demands of the market or
considerations as to how they might be
presented and thus provide us with a
direct link to his private vision
they were his own exercises prompted by
a desire to understand a variety of
natural phenomena particularly the
clouds the quote chief organs of
sentiment to quote constables phrase
which he then captured by molding the
imagery into carefully composed
allusions their universal appeal is not
surprising as we have not only seen
these guys but more importantly we have
experienced them meaning that they
invoke in all of us some shared
emotional memories and responses in this
type of shared experience between the
artist and the viewer underlies the
success of all great works of art so
we'll end this evening in the same way
that we can with constable whose work
will continue to inspire seduce excite
and surprise us by opening our eyes not
only to his personal vision but also to
the clouds and skies and perhaps the
heavens above thank you